Oh, Rhett, Rhett, please don't say that.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry for everything.
My darling, you're such a child.
You think that by saying "I'm sorry", all the past can be corrected.
Here, take my handkerchief.
Never, at any crisis of your life, have I known you to have a handkerchief.
Rhett, Rhett, where are you going?
I'm going to Charleston,...
...back where I belong.
Please, please, take me with you.
No. I'm through with everything here.
I want peace.
I want to see if somewhere, there isn't something left in life of charm and grace.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
No. I only know that I love you.
That's your misfortune.
Rhett!
Rhett, Rhett!
Rhett! If you go, where shall I go?
What shall I do?
Frankly, my dear, I don't give a damn.